of causality and experiments and we have
so edo's not here but we have both Kozma
and Steve here and Marcus hopefully will
be arriving and so I wanted to say just
a few things so if we know one theme
that comes out in terms of Arun alluded
this to this this morning and that's
sort of the first slides we were faced
with an enormous amounts of
observational data that we're trying to
make sense of and observational data
comes with its difficulties in sorting
out things like causality and also just
figuring out exactly how to make sense
of the data that we have and I wanted to
sort of point out that you know three
major issues that we face and I think
will be touched on in the discussions
that we go through one is is how do we
select which parts of graphs we see or
which parts of the world we see and so
there's basic sampling issues that are
associated with trying to envision the
world that we're going to be trying to
estimate things from so we don't
necessarily see all of the network we
could be seeing it with with measurement
error but also we have design issues of
exactly who we should be talking to and
how we should be sampling things and
there's ways in which this can be done
so that things are unbiased and there's
ways in which this things can be done so
that there's biases and so I think just
being aware of the fact that we're not
always getting a perfect look at the
world and figuring out how we can design
things to best get the data that we need
to get a non-biased or a correctable
estimation of the world is sort of an
important topic and that will come up
quite a bit here a second so that's one
form in which things could be biased
from from what we're looking at a second
is endogenous and this was an issue that
came up in the morning session and
networks forum for specific reasons and
they could be forming based on latent
variables that were not observing and
those could correlate with people's
behaviors and so ultimately if we're
trying to predict why people are friends
or why they're behaving in
ways if we can't see those latent
variables we might be missing important
pieces of the puzzle and so trying to
correct for selection issues is sort of
an overriding problem and you know the
the the ability of us to try and infer
what might be causing certain kinds of
relationships and correct for that is an
active area of research and a difficult
one and also leads to the value of
having controlled experiments so the
kinds of things that Michael was doing
this morning where one instead actually
observes the network formation and
observes the process completely allows
for us to two then control for those
things at some cost of putting things in
the laboratory one other thing I wanted
to talk about which was sort of
serendipitous that this came last night
by email so this is a that that
scientists don't like to talk about but
the this is the American Economic
Association has now launched a registry
for randomized control trials what does
this actually do it means that if you
want to do an experiment and you you
have to lay out your design before you
go to the field and start collecting
data right so the idea is that that I'm
not going to be able to expose figure
out what I'm going to actually run and
exactly what questions I'm going to ask
I have to give you the design and post
the design beforehand then I can go out
into the field and do it and then we
don't have a selection bias of what gets
reported and what gets put into the to
the literature and this is done just for
randomized control trials but we could
imagine doing this quite generally for
empirical work and I think it's it's
sort of a selection bias that is on top
of all the issues that we normally worry
about but is another important one to
sort of keep in mind what is what are
the consequences of ignoring this no so
it so actually this is a curious thing
first of all they did just randomized
control trials secondly the it's
completely voluntary and so all you all
you can do is you sticks up out there
and an ex post what it does is it
disappoints you if you write the paper
differently now you have to explain why
you didn't do what you set out to do
remind like a time stamp or something
yeah exactly so it just gets posted and
then there's a time stamping and you can
now some people can see that you know in
in 2013 Matt posted this as his research
design and then published a paper in
2015 and somehow the paper doesn't look
like the design and what happened in
between and so it disciplines you not to
be you know doing something ex post that
you weren't intending to do ex-ante or
not how many designs you yeah yeah I
stood there you could post a lot either
but but it said you know the idea that
is completely public is somehow
disciplines us to to be careful about
thinking through exactly what the design
is ex ante and not be selecting research
ex post so that's a something else for a
little bit outside the session itself
but it's an important one